the metropolitan police seek to
end street racing in the
community how are you greetings cristian
cásseres the police have put together a
team called a raid to carry out
interventions in neighborhoods of the
city and residents in the northeast of the valley
say they have noticed a great change in
excess of  speed of the cars that
travel through the streets has not seen as
many races compared to the beginning
of last year the police ask the
public to use their online tool
to report clandestine
and prudent drivers and
some local companies are
Showing their support because Ukraine, among
them, the liquor store ly, allows them to see
ads through their
Instagram account that they will stop selling and
withdraw products made in Russia from their
businesses. The liquor store has 19
stores in southern Nevada,
meanwhile, the Ukrainian community  will unite in
protest this weekend invite
the southern nevada public to show  ar his
support for the citizens ciu cranios and
denounce the russian aggression these are
images of the demonstration that took
place last weekend the
march is scheduled for him 3 in the
afternoon in front of the municipality o ser
hija where las vegas' in the  center and today
is Ash Wednesday for thousands of
Catholics and while the churches in
the valley continue to lift themselves from the
restrictions brought on by the pandemic,
most of the churches have regulated
their services without face masks
Lent services begin today
will be the first year since  that started the
pandemic the priest will
physically give ashes to everyone
present and the warm
temperatures continue when we step on the navel of the
week we will have another 70
degree day a really spring day
temperatures will continue to rise
reaching 80 degrees before falling
For the weekend I am Cristian
Cásseres with his great
Spanish ignition news good day
[Music]